Hello Freak bitches.
So before they started modifying genes,
how do they select,
like say,
how do they.
Cause before any genetic modifications
were done in laboratories,
they had turned this Goc,
what did I say?
A Toc,
Toc or maize as we used to call it,
right?
That was the Indian word for it.
Even now,
even according to that
commercial that says its.
Yeah,
well the maze is kind of a general
term for everything from a field corn,
which is what we think about,
which is fed to animals,
which 80 percent of GM crops go to animal
feed and we differentiate that versus
a what is typically done by humans,
which is usually sweet corn varieties.
So how did they turn it before there
was any genetic modifications done in
laboratories?
How did they turn that
corn into what we now,
which is delicious and sweet
and you put butter on it.
It's fantastic.
Oh Shit,
how did they do that?
Yeah,
actually.
But it was all just random mutations.
DNA random.
Yeah.
DNA replication is a sloppy process
and funny things happen when you,
uh,
from a environment.
So in the process of
replication of DNA itself,
you can make errors.
I'm cosmic radiation,
um,
just the chemicals in our environment,
natural chemicals that are out there can
induce changes in DNA and these kinds
of mutations sometimes very rarely
result in a change in the plant that's
beneficial and at least,
or at least from a human perspective.
So in all the plants that we've had,
all the plants that we have,
the significant amount of change has
come from random mutations that change
genes in ways we don't understand pieces
of DNA that get up out of the genome
and sit down somewhere else randomly.
They do this all the time.
Viruses in the plants that get into the
genome and sit down and places that we
have no idea where.
So genetic modification is something
that's ongoing and constant in a factor in
every genome,
including our own.
And so what we're seeing
today is just the,
uh,
the longterm effect that of humans who
have been able to put all the good traits
in one place.
So when you see those tomatoes that are
in the supermarket that are Pale and you
could play basketball with them,
those hard tomatoes and then you
compare them to like heirloom tomatoes.
The only difference between those two
is that someone had found some tomatoes
that had grown extra firm and selected
those and use the seeds from those to
create more similar tomatoes
and only select the dose.
Right?
So you frame two cool things here.
So heirloom what does an heirloom and an
heirloom tomato without standing eating
qualities that can't work in production
commercially because it's too mushy.
It's too mushy.
They don't last long and they break down.
But on the other hand,
so this is what the
problem is with our food.
When you talk about tomatoes,
strawberries,
blueberries,
things that these are non gmo by the way,
there is no gmo tomatoes or strawberries.
Not at all.
People would say there are.
The problem is is that plant breeding
over the last 50 years or say over the
last 100,
the.
The objectives of the
breeders has been bigger.
Fruit uniformity,
big yield,
disease resistance,
nothing about flavor and aroma.
So to meet production characteristics,
which is what we've been
selecting for breeders,
have been looking for these kinds of
characteristics that don't involve the
consumer and so our decline in the
flavors and the quality of fruits and
vegetables is directly
related to the mass breeding,
not anything to do with GMO.
So when you say genetic modified in,
in that,
in those terms,
they are kind of genetically modified,
but they're not modified in terms of
being in a laboratory and human beings
doing some funky stuff with jeans.
They're sort of modified almost
naturally and just selected for those
modifications.
Exactly.
And,
and some of the things that we've selected
for have been the ones that didn't
kill us when we ate them or the
things that didn't make a poison that,
uh,
or something that tasted horrible.
Um,
plants make lots of funky compounds.
And so this was an opportunity for us.
So what we've seen in our stores
right now is the residue of,
of thousands of years of human selection
and when we can call it genetic
modification if we want to,
but we can differentiate it from
what we do in the laboratory,
which is now we can call
adding a transgene where a
transgenesis moving a gene
from one background of genetics to another
via laboratory and these selections
that people have moaned
about and I have as well.
I mean,
it's horrible when you get a sandwich
and has a pale tomato on it because they
just taste awful though.
So there's no science involved in any
of that other than selection is no,
there's no.
There's no like injection of some alien
sort of genetics into those things.
Alien to the plant.
No,
there's no,
there's no syringes.
I'm nothing like that.
And it actually,
you know,
it is more an art than a science.
Being a plant breeder is the most kick
ass career these days and has been for a
long time.
Um,
plant breeding is essentially
inventing the next generation of food.
And all we're talking about is a mixing
pollen from things that maybe normally
wouldn't cross together like something
that nature would never cross,
but you got this cool tomato from Europe
that has great qualities and we can mix
it with this great production quality
tomato for that grows in Florida where
nothing else can grow.
And now you mix these two together and
you get this beautiful tomato that works
well and everybody's garden.
That's where we're going now.
But that's not gmo,
that's just using other types of
technology to facilitate this net,
this breeding process that breeders do.
Um,
but I think masculine aggression has
also given us so many of the goodies.
You want to go through the list of heaps
of fresh vegetables in the middle of
the wintertime.
Um,
all the inventions that
push us beyond our biology,
they takes.
It requires a little aggression.
I think sometimes,
and even,
God forbid,
I say
it,
competition,
ruthless competition,
things progressed.
The problem with that is that people
are going to lose and people don't like
lose them because they think
losing is a bad feeling.
So they think of competition and
competitive people as being negative.
Okay.
So that's what,
that's my worry about the
feminization quote unquote,
of our society.
I think that we have to be very careful
that we don't forget the positive
aspects of what you'd call
unoriginal macho energy.
I think the problem is that
it's not masculine energy.
That's a problem that
people were upset about.
I think it gets misconstrued.
I think the problem that we
all have is with assholes.
That is the problem across the board,
whether it's women or it's men when you
see like these crazy radical feminists
who uh,
a attack speakers because they want to
support men's rights in divorce court and
whatever the fucking reason
is that the really aggressive,
like there's this archetypal video of
this super aggressive feminist outside of
this thing in Toronto and she's got red
hair and she's screaming at people like
what she wants and what she doesn't
want from men and when they can shut the
fuck up and you know,
and she's telling people in the honest,
shut the fuck up the people that,
that exist like that.
Then they become the problem because the
problem is not like the idea that women
deserve everything that men deserve and
that we should have equal treatment by
law.
The problem is assholes.
Assholes representing a point of view
that I probably don't disagree with,
but I disagree with her and I disagree
with someone who is generalizing about an
entire gender because that's ridiculous.
Of course it is.
Or generalizing about a type of person
that is in that gender like you can't it.
Everybody is entitled to start from
zero and as soon as you are prejudice,
whether you're prejudice against white
people or whether you're prejudice
against men or with your prejudice against
gays are transgenders or whatever the
fuck it is.
As soon as you stop treating that person
as like an you come at them from a
totally even spot,
then he,
you're the asshole.
Right?
And I would suggest that,
you know,
we benefit also enjoy a lot about life
at based on people who created things,
whose motives their motives may
have been less than stellar.
Show.
A lot of people that are
driven by just pure ego,
domination,
greed,
and those things are not.
Those things do not
always create bad things.
In fact,
a lot of times they create
incredible innovations,
better ways to do things.
You know so much.
What is,
what's another word for innovation?
Another word for
innovation is destruction.
You're destroying how people used to do
it when we came up with a the combustion
internal combustion engine and put it
in a vehicle and turn it into a car.
People that he made a lot of money making,
buggy whips went out of fucking business.
So I don't need your fucking Buggy whip
because my car doesn't respond to buggy
whips in response to what I call rock oil,
which turned out to be oil.
So that's the other thing to keep in mind.
Innovation is,
is isn't aggressive competition thing.
It's competition.
It's destruction.